Привіт! Мене звати Елла Василівна.
Я вчитель історії 250 школи м. Києва
і запрошую вас на урок історії до 8 класу.
Тема сьогоднішнього уроку:
“Гетьманщина за часів Івана Мазепи
(кінець XVII - початок
XVIII ст.)”. Заняття друге.
Сподіваюсь, як завжди у вас:
підручник, зошит, ручка, олівці
– все це з собою. І
ми починаємо наш урок.
Отже, Іван Мазепа продовжує розбудовувати
свою державу. Але він прекрасно
розуміє, що ніяка держава без
освічених людей ніколи не відбудеться.
Через те, він величезну
кількість свого часу, зусиль
і коштів витрачає на
культурно-освітню діяльність.
І це виявилося дуже необхідним якраз
для Гетьманщини в пост-руїнний період.
Мазепинська Україна – це те
середовище і ті умови, які дозволили
українцям до сьогоднішнього
дня зберегти свою ідентичність.
Мазепа приділяє увагу освіті
і, перш за все, вищій освіті.
Він хоче, будучи сам освіченою
людиною, бачити навколо себе
козацьку старшину такими ж
самими грамотними, освіченими,
які можуть підтримати Гетьмана
в усіх скрутних ситуаціях.
Тим більше, що скрутних ситуацій
Гетьману Мазепі було не бракувати.
Отже, Іван Мазепа уважно
придивляється і твердо вирішує розвивати
Києво-Могилянський Колегіум.
Києво-Могилянський Колегіум для
Мазепи був щось на кшталт лабораторії,
де мали куватися українські,
національно-свідомі,
віддані козацькій справі люди.
Він наполегливо, листуючись
з Петром І, який став уже на
той час царем, – просить,
вимагає, пропонує, але в
1701 році домагається свого –
Києво-Могилянський Колегіум стає
Києво-Могилянською Академією.
Зверніть, будь ласка, увагу.
Чесно кажучи, це фрагмент
київського Подолу, але який
гармонійний, який гарний, який
впорядкований. Оцей шматочок
Гетьманщини візуалізує, показує – якою
уявляв собі Гетьманщину Іван Мазепа.
Іван Мазепа вважає, що
Києво-Могилянської Академії мало,
хоча там навчалося дуже багато студентів.
Відомо, що за часів Мазепи
одночасно могло навчатися десь до
2 000 студентів, притому що
Мазепа заохочував не зупинятися
на освіті Києво-Могилянської
Академії, а рухатися далі.
Він дуже підтримував тих
студентів, які після закінчення
Києво-Могилянської Академії,
вирушали вчитися за кордон.
Період Мазепи – це період найбільш
масових освітніх поїздок за кордон
української молоді. Але повертаємося
до нашого зображення на дошці.
І ви бачите, знову ж, дуже гарне
приміщення. Притому, що приємно
сказати – воно збереглося от
в такому вигляді розкішному до
сьогоднішнього дня. Уявіть собі,
як серйозно до архітектури, до
будівництва – яким вимогливим був
Мазепа. Це Чернігівський Колегіум.
Так само – вищий заклад на ті часи.
Він був створений і відкритий у 1700 році.
І це був перший вищий навчальний
заклад на Лівобережній Україні.
Мазепа завжди говорив, що йому подобаються
книжні люди – ті, хто створюють
книги і ті, хто книги читають.
Справа в тому, що сам Мазепа багато
читав. Він купував книги, замовляв
книги. І пам’ятаєте, на минулому уроці
у вас було невеличке завдання
порахувати – а скільки мов знав Мазепа?
Сім. Порахували? Загалом
він володів сімома мовами,
можливо і більше. Розумів,
кажуть, він набагато більше мов.
Але Мазепа, мандруючи по Європі,
Мазепа з дипломатичними місіями
виїжджаючи в різні куточки царства,
королівства – за все своє життя
зібрав дуже розкішну бібліотеку.
Ви знаєте, коли Пилип
Орлик опинився у вигнанні
за кордоном, то він багато
речей згадував з часів
Гетьманщини і особливо він
згадував бібліотеку Мазепи.
Він казав, що такої бібліотеки,
яка була у Івана Степановича,
не було у жодної людини по всій Україні.
Мазепа дуже тішився, якщо
йому вдавалося придбати якусь
особливу книгу. Зверніть,
будь ласка, увагу на екран.
Ви бачите, що перед вами дві світлини
– це сучасні світлини. А от зображена
на цих світлинах абсолютно раритетна
річ – це Пересопницьке Євангеліє.
Справа в тому, що невідомо точно
– коли Мазепа придбав його.
Але ми знаємо, що цьому Євангелію, коли
воно потрапило до рук Мазепи,
уже було більше ста років. Мазепа
його придбав за великі гроші, а потім
подарував Переяславському Собору,
де довгий час воно і зберігалося.
Сьогодні Пересопницьке Євангеліє
зберігається в книгосховищах.
І так само, як і в ті давні часи,
Євангеліє використовувалося
не тільки для того, щоби
здійснювати богослужіння.
За часів Мазепи казали – Євангеліє
навчає і на Євангелії клянуться.
Так от і сьогодні ви знаєте, що
на Пересопницькому
Євангелії кожен наступний
Президент складає присягу
перед народом України.
Це Пересопницьке Євангеліє
придбав спочатку до своєї колекції,
а потім подарував до храму
саме Іван Степанович Мазепа.
Іван Мазепа мав дуже
теплі стосунки з Церквою.
На Церкву він покладав
величезні надії.
Церква об’єднувала народ – вважав
Іван Мазепа.
Церква втішала народ, Церква давала
поради. Сам він був глибоковіруючою
людиною, хоча дехто йому
закидає, і ми знаємо чому так сталося,
- пліток і міфів про Мазепу
після його смерті з’явилося чимало -
але Мазепі закидали,
що він і єзуїт, і протестант.
Ні. Він був щирий християнин,
він був православний
і він дуже шанував Православну Церкву.
Єдине, що засмучувало Івана
Мазепу – це те, що Українська Церква
ще за Самойловича потрапила
під опіку московського Патріарха.
Але Мазепа намагався
свої печалі і свої турботи
ховати глибоко в
душі, кожен день засвідчуючи
глибоку повагу і підтримку
Українській Православній Церкві.
Він будував багато церков,
багато соборів.
Подивіться, будь ласка – лише
декілька зразків:
Богоявленський собор
Києво-Братського монастиря,
військовий Микільський собор, Церква
всіх святих
над брамою Києво-Печерської Лаври.
Зверніть увагу, до речі, на цю Церкву усіх
святих. Тому що, якщо ви будете гортати
малюнки, які створював
Т.Г.Шевченко,
то саме ця церква є в колекції малюнків,
створених Т.Г.Шевченком.
Звичайно – це не весь
перелік. Хто каже, що він встиг
побудувати, що називається
– з фундаменту,
більше двох десятків церков.
Хтось називає більшу цифру.
Вчені досліджують і
говорять: неважливо скільки
побудував, він багато і
реставрував, давав кошти
і з козацького скарбу,
і з власної кишені.
Він відроджував, відбудовував
церкви.
Він допомагав реставрувати монастирі
по всій Лівобережній Україні.
Церква була вдячна, шанувала
і підтримувала Івана Мазепу.
Подивіться, я б хотіла, щоб ви
звернули увагу на архітектуру цих споруд.
Вона велична, дуже красива
і дуже схожа між собою.
Справа в тому, що всі ті будови,
які були створені за часів Мазепи
– вони мали особливий колорит,
вони мали козацький стиль
і ввійшли в історію як козацьке,
або мазепинське бароко.
Визначною рисою внутрішньої
політики Івана Мазепи було
прагнення об’єднати землі Лівобережжя,
Правобережжя, Запоріжжя та Слобожанщини
в єдине державне утворення.
Гетьман Мазепа мріяв про єдину,
Соборну – велику єдину Гетьманщину.
І знову ж без аналізу ситуації
Мазепі було не обійтись.
В своїй думі він пише так.
Ви бачите думу Мазепи на екрані.
Він усвідомлював, що об’єднати
українські землі в одну Соборну державу –
це надскладне завдання.
Справа в тому, що цьому будуть
заважати і сусідні держави, але
він може не знайти підтримки і
всередині Гетьманщини. Справа в
тому, що спочатку Мазепа звернув увагу
на Правобережну Україну, і
звернув він на неї не випадково.
Ми знаємо, що Правобережна Україна
потрапила під владу Речі Посполитої,
частина її земель контролювалися
Османською імперією, частина
земель були незаселені. Козацтво
знаходилося в жалюгідному стані.
Але на цих землях весь час
відбувалися змагання між державами.
Зокрема Речі Посполитої,
Московського царства і Османської імперії
за володіння цими територіями.
Кожен з правителів
прагнув знайти собі підтримку
серед місцевого населення.
І король Речі Посполитої, і московський
цар, і турецький султан з кримським ханом
- вони намагалися загравати з козаками,
тому що козаки могли
стати тою реальною силою,
яка могла б допомогти їм у
їхніх змаганнях за ці території.
Тим більше, що як казали в той
час на Правобережжі – у козаків шаблі
ще не затупіли, а
майстерність не забулася.
І кожен з цих правителів
наввипередки обіцяв то одне,
то друге, то … Виникало
питання – хто дотримає слово?
В той час найвпливовішим на Правобережжі
був якраз король Речі Посполитої.
Звали його Ян ІІІ Собеський.
І я виписала сюди на дошку
лише декілька цитат і трошечки
їх прокоментую. Перше, що казав
Ян ІІІ Собеський, притому, що ця
фраза дуже дратувала польських магнатів,
але то була правда. Він казав: “При кому
козаки, при тому й залишиться Україна”.
Тобто, ви бачите – наскільки високо
ставив польський король козаків,
наскільки він намагався порозумітися
з ними, при цьому – не обіцяючи
ніяких особливих привілеїв.
Наступна фраза. Одного разу
Ян ІІІ Собеський виступав у Сеймі
перед магнатами і коли він знову
заговорив про Україну, його почали
звинувачувати, що він, начебто,
підтримує козаків, він не захищає
інтересів польської шляхти … На що
Ян ІІІ Собеський відповів таке:
“А ви пригадайте Хотин”. А ви пригадали
Хотинську битву? Ян ІІІ Собеський
сказав: “Скільки там було вояків?
Під Хотином було 40 000 козаків,
а об’єднане польсько-литовське
військо змогло зібрати тільки 60 000”.
Він спитав: “А завдяки кому
ми перемогли у Хотинській битві?”
Ян ІІІ Собеський говорив ще таке:
“Треба дякувати Богові, щоб козаки
побрали гроші і служили нам”.
Тобто, він готовий був наймати на
службу, він готовий був домовлятися.
Єдине, чим він не готовий був
поступитися – це не дарувати
козакам остаточно свободи і вольності.
Він говорив дуже таку
рішучу, екстремальну фразу:
“Українські землі мають належати
козакам…”. Можна було б тут
поставити крапку, але – ні. Ян ІІІ
Собеський казав:
“… але тим козакам, яких
визнає його королівська милість”.
Тобто тих людей, кого в списку він
побачить і визнає, та затвердить козаками
– ті можуть бути козаками і
можуть розраховувати на якісь
привілеї, на якісь земельні
наділи. Тих, кого польський король
не вважатиме козаками – вони ні
на що не повинні розраховувати.
На початку 1684 року
король у своєму універсалі до
правобережного козацтва дозволив
йому колонізувати українські землі,
що були винищені попередніми
війнами.
Тобто король дозволив розселятися на
розорених землях.
Виникає питання – розселятися то
розселятися, а які права на ці землі
будуть мати козаки? Ви
пам’ятаєте, на попередньому уроці ми
говорили з вами про систему
займанщини. Зайняти вільні
землі – нехитра справа.
Обробляти їх – українське населення
залюбки обробляло землі.
Але де гарантія, що не з’являться
колишні власники – польські
магнати, польська шляхта і
не відбере це все. І не
пропаде праця, і ще й не будуть
покарані ті люди, які займуть
вільні землі.
Тоді що зробив Ян ІІІ Собеський?
В 1684 році він офіційно відновив
“Військо Запорозьке Його
Королівської Милості”.
Дуже гарна назва. Правда? “Військо
Запорозьке Його Королівської Милості”.
Лише одне – реєстр цього
війська складав 2 000 козаків.
Рішення короля не було
остаточним,
доки його не затвердить Сейм,
ви ж знаєте правила Речі Посполитої.
В 1685 році на Сеймі була дуже жвава
дискусія – кричали,
сварилися,
але все-таки прийшли до
єдиної думки і цю думку навіть
називали так іронічно,
правда, але – Конституцією
для Правобережної
України, тому що саме цей
Сейм підтвердив
козацькі права і вольності.
Дозволялося створити чотири полки.
Якщо можете (я би вам радила це
зробити), запишіть назви цих полків.
На чолі кожного полку стояв полковник.
Запишіть прізвища полковників.
Єдине – що козацькі полки не мали
права самостійно обирати Гетьмана.
Гетьмана призначав король.
Призначив Наказного Гетьмана для
Правобережної України
ще в другій половині 70-х років. Один
Гетьман змінював іншого. Але ви розумієте,
Наказний Гетьман – це тимчасовий Гетьман.
Це Гетьман, якого не обирали козаки
на козацькій Раді, бо козацької Ради як
такої, за задумом Яна Собеського
і за уявою польського
Сейму, не повинно було бути.
В ідеалі магнати хотіли щоб полковники
підкорялися польським воєводам,
Коронному Гетьману. Головнокомандувач війська
був Коронний Гетьман у Речі Посполитій.
Найактивнішим, найяскравішим
серед усіх чотирьох полковників був
фастівський полковник Семен Палій.
І ви знаєте, козаки створивши полки –
вони почали відроджувати той лад і
порядок, який існував ще за
часів Богдана Хмельницького.
Та й до Богдана Хмельницького.
І все їх загалом
вдавалося, тому що, будучи
зацікавлені в козаках,
польська влада (король, Сейм)
не дуже контролювали
в той час внутрішнє життя
козацького суспільства.
Власне вони воліли загравати
в такий спосіб з козаками,
тому що в любий момент
могла початися серйозна війна з
Турецькою Османською імперією
і козаки знадобилися б польському королю.
Через те, дивіться як писав
магнат Степан Пісочинський.
Він казав: “Козаки у
цих місцях … узурпували
владу … підкорили наш
край, …”. Дивно Правобережжя
називати нашим краєм.
Правда? “…чинячи такий опір,
що навряд чи хтось із нас
зможе сюди повернутися.
Козаки утворили у
Подніпров’ї свій удільний край.”
Це дуже турбувало поляків, але
поки що вони нічого не могли зробити.
На дошці лише три дати, ніякого тексту.
Але я радила би вам записати ці дати.
В 1699 році укладається угода між
Річчю Посполитою і Османською імперією.
Османська імперія
зрікається своїх претензій на
Правобережну Україну. Війни між
Річчю Посполитою
і Османською імперією на
якийсь час припиняються.
Через те – чи потрібне козацтво?
Абсолютно ні. І тоді
польський король і польський Сейм
однозначно вирішили – у
козаків землі забрати, привілеїв
і прав позбавити і, власне,
зламати все те життя,
яке вже було побудоване за дуже
короткий час козаками на Правобережжі.
Що робить Семен Палій?
Він самий рішучий
з чотирьох полковників. Він тут же, як
тільки дізнався в 1699 році
про таку ситуацію, пише
листа польському королю.
Він каже: Фастів побудував
я, це моя земля і нікому її
повертати не буду. А потім
взагалі він звертається
до короля – що так не можна поводитися:
був дозвіл короля, було рішення Сейму
і раптом така підступна зрада.
Семен Палій чекав відповіді.
Чекав день, тиждень, місяць –
відповіді нема. Польський
король і не збирався писати.
Тоді Семен Палій починає
спілкуватися з іншими козаками,
з іншими полковниками і
каже: нам треба боротися.
Виникло питання – а чи допоможе
Іван Мазепа?
Чи допоможе московський цар?
Чесно кажучи, Палій не знав,
що відповісти, тому що ще в 1688
році він писав московському царю
і просив допомоги, просив взяти
Правобережжя під свою руку,
просив відібрати
ці землі у всіх загарбників.
Але московський цар також не
відповів. Якось прикро виходить
– Семен Палій пише, йому ніхто не
відповідає. Але він знову сподівався,
що ситуація змінилася – сьогодні
козаки на Правобережжі окріпли,
сьогодні вони бойова сила. І якщо
вони піднімуться на повстання,
то московський цар, напевно, обов’язково
прийде на допомогу козакам Правобережжя.
Пришле, як мінімум,
Івана Мазепу зі своїми полками і
Правобережжя перейде від зрадливого
польського короля під руку
московського царя, а дві території України
з’єднаються в одну спільну Гетьманщину.
1700 рік – перші виступи. В перших
виступах козаки отримують перемогу
за перемогою. Справа в тому, що це
свідчило не стільки про силу козаків
… Про відчайдушність – однозначно,
але не про силу козаків. Мова про
те, що саме в цей час починається
Північна війна. Шведські війська
атакують кордони Речі Посполитої.
Основне військо знаходиться саме
на тій арені бойових дій. І в якийсь
час польські магнати та шляхта
розгубилися. В них не вистачало сили.
Вони думали, що справляться малою кров’ю,
але в перших сутичках вони
раз за разом програвали повстанцям.
В 1701 році, зрозумівши, що ситуація дуже
складна, поляки збирають більші сили,
а козаки піднімаються по
всій Правобережній Україні.
Мова іде про Київщину,
Брацлавщину і частину Волині.
Це вже дуже схоже на справжню війну.
Ви знаєте, в той час козаки
згадували Богдана Хмельницького.
В наш час вчені, історики кажуть: це було
дуже схоже на таку оновлену Хмельниччину –
боротьба за визволення.
Ось наш герой – Семен Палій. Взагалі
– людина виняткова.
Людина, якій на той час було вже 60
років, але бойового духу
і запалу в нього було
настільки, що молоді не
завжди з ним справлялися.
Коли Семен Палій
рубав шаблюкою, то рівних
йому важко було знайти.
Чого написано Гурко (дехто з
восьмикласників питає)?
Справа в тому, що Палій –це
його козацьке прізвисько.
Інколи казали, що коли йде в бій
Семен Гурко (а це його прізвище)
– то горить земля під ногами
усіх ворогів, що він палить і
вогнем, і мечем всіх супостатів,
які хочуть зашкодити козацтву,
Гетьманству та посполитим.
Подивіться як його називав
Ян Собеський: “Віденський богатир”.
Семен Палій очолював загін,
який разом з військами Яна
Собеського воював проти турків.
З 1702 року починається особлива сторінка
в історії Правобережжя.
Вона називається “Паліївщина” від імені
лідера повстанського руху.
Паліївщина тривала
недовго – 1702-1704 рік.
Але вона увійшла назавжди
в історію українського визвольного руху.
Це приклад перемог.
Це приклад боротьби без надії перемогти.
Це приклад зради і це
приклад великої надії.
Трішки практичного завдання.
Ви знаєте – найскладніше учням,
(чесно кажучи, інколи і моїм колегам)
визначити передумови і
причини будь-якої історичної події.
Часто це плутається.
Перед вами на екрані передумови
повстання під проводом Семена Палія.
А нижче, завдання для вас – визначити
причини.
Щоб правильно справитися з цим завданням,
нам треба знати один маленький
секрет. Причини – це завдання, які
перед собою ставили
люди в тій чи іншій ситуації.
Наприклад, маленька підказка,
Передумовами повстання:
“У зв’язку з переходом правобережних
українських земель від Туреччини до Речі
Посполитої відпала потреба в козацтві,
тому польський Сейм розпустив козацькі
формування”. Тобто, це умови, які склалися.
Яке завдання було перед Палієм
і його товаришами-побратимами?
От ту відповідь, яку ви сказали
– це і є причина повстання.
Дивимося наступний крок.
“Полковникам Палію, Абазіну, Іскрі,
Барабашу наказано розпустити
полки”. Прийшло розпорядження
зробити ось так. Яке завдання
поставлять перед собою полковники?
Ваша відповідь і буде причиною повстання.
Останнє прочитайте самі
і виконайте самостійно.
Зверніть увагу на карту. Сьогодні,
напевно, це перша карта
на нашому уроці. Але вона дуже важлива.
Бачите, світлим кольором – то територія
Гетьманщини під орудою Івана Мазепи.
А ось на Правобережжі чорним кольором
виділена територія, яку охопило
повстання під назвою Паліївщина.
Подивіться, на якийсь час повсталі козаки
контролювали землі лише трохи
менші, ніж землі Гетьманщини.
Коли козаки почали перемагати,
у них з’явилася ідея
взагалі поляків вигнати
з Правобережжя і
повністю звільнити Україну.
Але – не сталося так, як гадалося.
Хронологічна таблиця.
Пам’ятаєте – хронологічна таблиця:
записується дата, визначні події.
Прошу роздивитися її.
І бачите, що в 1703 році польські
війська починають поступово перемагати.
Одне за другим вони беруть міста
Правобережжя, козаки відступають.
Козаки в цей час раз за разом
звертаються про допомогу до Мазепи,
до Петра І, але звідти – жодної
вісточки (офіційної у всякому випадку).
Майже зневірившись у
перемозі, але не бажаючи
припинити боротьбу, козаки в 1704
році начебто отримали друге дихання.
Повстання набуває нового підйому
і розгорається з новою силою.
А в цей час, не маючи можливості
воювати одночасно зі шведами,
які наступають, і з козаками,
які повстали, польський король
Август ІІ Саксонець звертається з
листом до брата царя, як він називав
Петра І: прийди і допоможи. Прийди і
допоможи розправитися з повстанцями,
і допоможи воювати з шведським
королем. Це той самий 1704 рік.
Петро І дає наказ Мазепі
виступити з козаками за Дніпро
на правий берег. Ви уявляєте ситуацію?
Мазепа отримав конкретне завдання –
прийти на допомогу
польському королю, а не Семену Палію.
Мазепа іде на правий берег, щоб
громити шведів разом з поляками,
а не допомагати повсталим козакам.
Але козаки про це не знали.
Вони з такою радістю і надією вітали
прихід Мазепи, вони одразу заявили,
що готові стати під його булаву…
Але Мазепа повівся не
так, як очікували повстанці.
Мазепа перше що зробив
– наказав заарештувати Палія.
Всі інші полковники залишилися на
своїх посадах. Залишилися полки і,
більше того, за наказом Мазепи
було дозволено створити ще три полки
на території Правобережної
України. А Палія звинуватили у зраді.
Тому що, в умовах польсько-шведської
війни, воюючи проти польського короля –
на чиїй стороні, начебто, був Палій? На
шведській, отже він – зрадник.
Через те Палія заарештовують і, як вже
було прийнято, відправляють на лівий берег,
а потім до Сибіру.
Загалом, повстання провалилося.
Але і польський король не мав сили
контролювати ці землі. І по неписаним
домовленостям землі Правобережжя
потрапляють під оруду Івана Мазепи.
Збулася мрія, яка довгий час зберігалася
в душі, серці і голові Івана Мазепи – він
об’єднав два береги Дніпра:
Лівобережну Гетьманщину і Правобережні полки.
Тепер він став Гетьманом
обох берегів України.
На цьому ми закінчуємо
наш урок.
Що було далі – поговоримо
на наступному занятті.
І я дякую вам за увагу!